if I send my kid to a school in New York
City a public school he has to be
vaccinated he has to have vaccination
records these migrant children they
don't that's an issue because if there's
an outbreak of something like measles
it's spreading to these kids some of
them who can't be vaccinated because
they're immunocompromised they can't get
a vaccine and none of the migrant kids
coming in have to be vaccinated at all
they don't they're not held to the same
standards as the children of citizens
there of New Yorkers of people in this
country they don't they don't care yeah
but you look at a state like Texas guys
and I know everybody thinks Texas is
conservative but now with Dallas Austin
San Antonio and Houston all being
liberal now the great replacement Theory
it's
in Texas we are being affected by
immigration probably worse other than
California and Arizona worse than
anybody in the entire country and it's
done on purpose a state that was likely
conservative in the next 10 years no
doubt will be liberal
they hate the rule a lot